back now at 7 30 here on CBS mornings
and the prosecution in the double murder
trial of Alex murdaugh is expected to
rest its case today follows three weeks
of testimony related to the 2021
killings of Murdoch's wife and son the
lawyer disgraced lawyer has pleaded not
guilty in those killings and Nikki
Batiste has been following this case
every twist and turn from the very
beginning and she joins us now Nikki
good morning good morning Alex Murdoch's
defense team could call its first
Witnesses today the defense will likely
point to what it says is a subpar
investigation a weak motive and no
murder weapon to directly link Murdoch
to the murders
jurors this week were shown footage of
investigators questioning Alex murdaugh
in August 2021 two months after his wife
Maggie and Son Paul were shot and killed
on the families hunting estate
so does that mean that I am a suspect
prosecutors have painted Murdoch as a
manipulative man who con people out of
millions of dollars for years they claim
he killed his wife and son in an attempt
to distract from those alleged Financial
crimes before they came to light as a
part of a separate civil case involving
his son Paul who was charged with
driving under the influence in a boat
crash that killed a 19 year old girl my
son was in a boat wreck of a months back
he's been getting threats police body
camera footage from the night of the
murders shows Murdoch suggesting that
Killer's motive was revenge for the
Boating incident I know there's somebody
I know that's what it is prosecutors
also played a social media video
recorded by Murdoch's son which they say
showed him around an hour before the
murders wearing a different outfit from
the white t-shirt and shorts he had on
when police arrived CBS News legal
analyst Ricky cleeman so the prosecution
may have been very very effective
but it's getting to that motive that
becomes the stretch during
cross-examinations the defense
characterized Murdoch as a loving family
man with no motive to kill his wife and
son Alex murdal's defense team told me
they're considering putting him on the
stand what might their strategy be
the strategy of putting a defendant on
the witness stand is the highest risk
Alex murdo's past is filled with trouble
as a witness he would be a prosecutor's
cross-examination Dream the ultimate
decision for a defendant to testify or
not belongs to the defendant alone it is
always possible that his lawyers don't
want him to testify and he's going to
insist on testifying anyway
this morning we expect to hear more
testimony from an investigator regarding
a bizarre incident three months after
the murders where Alex Murdoch allegedly
asked a friend to shoot him in the head
as part of a botched suicide scheme the
defendant Murdoch told investigators he
wanted to leave a 10 million dollar life
insurance payout for his surviving son
Buster and Buster murdaugh is one of the
Witnesses on the defense list we expect
to hear from him I want to make one
point that I think the defense will want
to reiterate we heard from a forensic
expert during the witnesses from the
prosecutors that there was unidentified
male DNA under Maggie murdaugh Alex's
wife's fingernails they do not know who
it belongs to they have ruled out Alex
Murdoch and Palmer doll so I think that
something defense will really want to
bring up again of course they don't know
how it got there obviously don't know
how it got there there are a lot of ways
DNA can be transferred there were so
many I was just going to say the exact
same thing and it the more you hear the
crazier it gets yes indeed it's
complicated very much so thank you thank
you